>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Next up is Canadian
Visual Artist Sarah Hatton.
Sarah's deep interest in human
nature and insatiable curiosity
about the natural works are
found throughout her paintings
and mixed media work.
Through her paintings and projects,
she observes and explores notions
of longing, transition, morality,
and human connections with nature.
She's here today to share
about her process of creating.
Please welcome Sarah Hatton.
[ Applause ]
>> Sarah Hatton: Thank you.
I'm Sarah.
I'm a visual artist
from Ottawa, Canada.
I'm a lifelong naturalist.
I like challenging myself
in horticultural ways.
I grew the only giant
sequoia from seed
but it survived the Canadian
winter six times in a row.
Of course, like any millennial,
the little tree has its
own Twitter account.
I'm also a beekeeper.
Now if there's one thing I can
say about my artwork, in general,
it's that science and nature always
seem to make an experience in it.
It's something I just
can't switch off.
I was invited here today to talk
about my latest series of work,
which is called Attachment.
But I thought I would give you a bit
of background into a previous series
of work that I did just
so that you can start
to see the connections
that I'm talking about.
So, 2013 was not a good year for
bees -- not a good year for my bees,
as well as some of the
other beekeepers' colonies
in the region that I live in.
I lost all of my colonies and
because we're a tight network,
beekeepers, I was learning
more and more
about colony [inaudible]
disorder, the global bee crisis
and systemic pesticides that have
been thought to be causing a lot
of the problems with the bees.
So, when I lost my hives, I wanted
to do something meaningful with them
so that I could start some
activism and start to talk
about was happening to them.
But I didn't know what to do.
I had all of these --
thousands of dead bodies
and I didn't have the idea yet,
so what does one do in that case?
I bagged them up in Zip-locks
and I put them in my freezer
until I had my eureka moment.
My family is either really
understanding about this
or they're just resigned
to the stuff that I do now.
And the eureka moment
came when I thought
about the mathematical patterns
that are inherent in nature,
particularly the Fibonacci
sequence of math that is found
in seed producing plants,
like the sunflower.
And it was these patterns
that gave me my inspiration
for what to finally do.
These are the sorts of crops that
are treated with the same pesticides
that are thought to be
destroying the bees.
So, I glued -- one by one -- all of
the honeybees into these patterns
and then I coated them with resin.
And the resulting work --
this is the prototype
and I get to do a cool,
badass art disclaimer here that
some of these patterns tend
to use the sense of vertigo in
some viewers so if you start
to feel uncomfortable,
just close your eyes.
These are 4 feet across.
So, these are -- because systemic
pesticides affect the bee's central
nervous system and they wipe out
the ability to navigate and get back
to their hives, I chose patterns
from crop circles as well
that gave a similar affect --
an optical illusion effect
to the viewer and gave
that same sense of disorientation.
That's another piece that's
4 feet by 4 feet circle.
It's about 10,000 bees
in that piece.
So, you can read study after study
of the data behind the bee decline
but when you look at art, art
gives you that visceral gut-punch
of emotion that tells you what the
story is behind what you're seeing.
This series got quite a
bit of international press,
partly because I think
of the timing of it,
the bee decline was just starting
to be recognized but also,
not a lot of artists out these
using thousands of dead bees
as their medium, I don't --
I hope that's still the case.
So, what I want you
to think about here is
that I've used a single
item repeated on math
to send a specific message through
a symbolic pattern, which brings me
to my next series of work.
So, meanwhile in Canada, Library
in Archives Canada, our colleagues
to the north, have started
their mass digitization project.
It's a multiyear, enormous
project with many,
many resources devoted to it.
and that's the digitization of the
complete collection of the CEF,
Canadian Expeditionary
Force World War I files.
And this is an enormous undertaking
and the data that will be produced
by the digitization project, a
treasure in itself, but there --
as anyone who has done a mass
digitization project knows,
there's byproducts
that come from it,
you have to hire additional
staff to process the files.
These are paper records
that have been held together
for a hundred years by pins,
stapes, and paperclips.
And when I turned the preservation
center, the thing that struck me,
as an aside from the immensity of
the project, was that they had bin,
after bin, after bin of these brass
pins that held the records together
that had been taken apart and it
struck me as so moving to see --
physically represented
in front of me --
the number of people that this was.
And I asked them, what are you
going to do with all of these pins?
And they said, well, we want to do
something to commemorate the project
but we're not quite sure what.
We're thinking of maybe melting them
all down and making metals or coins.
And I thought -- that didn't
sit well with me because I had
that reaction to seeing the number
of them and these were items
that held together Canada's
military memory for a hundred years,
you can't just take
that kind of destroy it
by melting it all together,
there's something there.
Again, waiting for my eureka
moment, I said, give me one of them
to take home and I'll think about
this and see what I come up with.
So, I took one of them back and I
was just sitting there looking at it
and I thought each one of these
fasteners has been embossed,
it was the style of the
time, with a star, eureka.
So, this is what I did.
>> This is a single
brass fastener pin.
It's 100-years-old.
These are the pins that held
together the military service
records of each Canadian soldier
who served in the First World War.
When Library and Archives Canada
began their mass digitization
of soldier's files, each of these
pins had to be detached by hand.
In total, there were
640,000 of them.
Nobody knew what to do
with all of this brass
and so they asked an artist.
>> Sarah Hatton: I wanted to do
something with these fasteners
that would preserve their
meaning as historical artifacts
but it would also find a respectful
way to convey the magnitude
of human loss during [inaudible].
Each fastener is stamped with a star
and there's unmistakable military
symbolism attached to the gold star
when you think about the sacrifice
that these families have made
and it was that that gave
me my inspiration for this.
I started by focusing on the five
major battles of the First World War
that involved the Canadian's
Expeditionary Force.
>> After determining the
geographical coordinates of each
of these battles, Hatton
generated star maps
of what the skies would have looked
like on the nights following each
of these major conflicts.
Then she got to work.
[ Music ]
The result is a series of star
charts titled, Detachment.
These pieces show us exactly how
the stars appeared 100 years ago,
the first night after the fighting
was over, the skies that, no doubt,
the surviving soldiers would
have been looking up at.
>> Sarah Hatton: This series
is a tribute piece, sacrifice,
timelessness, and remembrance.
Regardless of your political view,
stars are a cross cultural constant
that we look to for direction,
whether that's spiritual
or navigational.
They're a universal
way that we recognize
and memorialize the fallen.
[ Music ]
I want to express my
sincere gratitude to Library
and Archives Canada for pointing
me in this direction and to --
in particular -- Library
and Archivist [Foreign name]
for his support in this project.
And I also want to thank
the Library of Congress
for inviting me here today to share
this with you, it's been an honor.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.